[Music]
the largest organ in your body isn't
your liver or your brain it's your skin
with a surface area of about 20 square
feet in adults though different areas of
the skin have different characteristics
much of this surface performs similar
functions such as sweating feeling heat
and cold and growing hair but after a
deep cut or wound the newly healed skin
will look different from the surrounding
area and may not fully regain all its
abilities for a while or at all to
understand why this happens we need to
look at the structure of the human skin
the top layer called the epidermis
consists mostly of hardened cells called
keratinocytes and provides protection
since its outer layer is constantly
being shed and renewed it's pretty easy
to repair but sometimes a wound
penetrates into the dermis which
contains blood vessels and the various
glands and nerve endings that enable the
skins many functions and when that
happens it triggers the four overlapping
stages of the regenerative process the
first stage hemostasis is the skins
response to two immediate threats that
you're now losing blood and that the
physical barrier of the epidermis has
been compromised as the blood vessels
tightened to minimize the bleeding in a
process known as vasoconstriction both
threats are averted by forming a blood
clot a special protein known as fibrin
forms cross links on the top of the skin
preventing blood from flowing out and
bacteria or pathogens from getting in
after about three hours of this the skin
begins to turn red signaling the next
stage inflammation with bleeding under
control and the barrier secured the body
sends special cells to fight any
pathogens that may have gotten through
among the most important of these are
white blood cells known as macrophages
which devour bacteria and damage tissue
through a process known as phage o
cytosis in addition to producing growth
factors to spur healing and because
these tiny soldiers need to travel
through the blood to get to the wound
site the previously constricted blood
vessels now acts
and in a process called vasodilation
about two to three days after the wound
the proliferative stage occurs when
fibroblast cells begin to enter the
wound in the process of collagen
deposition they produce a fibrous
protein called collagen in the wound
site forming connective skin tissue to
replace the fibrin from before as
epidermal cells divide to reform the
outer layer of skin the dermis contracts
to close the wound finally in the fourth
stage of remodeling the wound matures as
the newly deposited collagen is
rearranged and converted into specific
types through this process which can
take over a year the tensile strength of
the new skin is improved and blood
vessels and other connections are
strengthened with time the new tissue
can reach from fifty to eighty percent
of some of its original healthy function
depending on the severity of the initial
wound and on the function itself but
because the skin does not fully recover
scarring continues to be a major
clinical issue for doctors around the
world and even though researchers have
made significant strides in
understanding the healing process many
fundamental mysteries remain unresolved
for instance do fibroblast cells arrive
from the blood vessels or from skin
tissue adjacent to the wound and why do
some other mammals such as deer heal
their wounds much more efficiently and
completely than humans
by finding the answers to these
questions and others we may one day be
able to heal ourselves so well that
scars will be just a memory
you
[Music]